volunteering makes us more human what do
you say about this one welcome back to
our next episode of the series called
language shapes perception and the topic
that we're tackling today is called
volunteering and how volunteering makes
us more human
volunteering is at the very core of
being a human no one has made it through
life without someone else's help that's
what Heather French Henry has to say
about volunteering for most people a
volunteer is someone who contributes
with time to help others without
expecting payment or other material gain
volunteering is giving your time and
energy to someone else's benefit
and it's also important because when
you're doing something for someone
else's good you will have a sense of
accomplishment a self-confidence and
even feel a little bit satisfied
and
um the the better you feel about
yourself the more likely you are to have
a positive outlook on your future life
on your goals and on everything you're
working through
volunteering helps us become more human
because it benefits both the person who
shares
the love or who does the volunteering
and also helps the person who receives
it it also helps us to meet other people
and and make new friends there are
several companies in the world that
employ people that do volunteering
volunteering
or do voluntary work
there are several companies in the world
that employ people
that do voluntary work
so people not only help different
companies but also create a future for
their career volunteering is considered
a social activity and as such enables
social integration and the creation of
new relationships directly and
positively affecting the volunteers
mental health one of the most well-known
benefits of volunteering is the impact
on the community is the impact on a
person's perspective on life is an
impact on on the person's mood and also
it's definitely an impact on the
person's idea of humanity volunteering
lets you connect with a certain
community and makes it a better place
even helping with a small list of tasks
can make a real difference in people's
lives and they will create a good
opinion for for the world based on on
the on the small act of kindness or the
the voluntary work that you did for them
also by becoming part of an activity for
the good of the community
volunteering increases self-confidence
and personal efficiency
volunteering for good
volunteering for Good Deeds removes
problematic behaviors builds a better
character of the person who is doing it
and strengthens trust between people
volunteering enables people to develop
leadership skills they begin to engage
and they are able to understand the
problems of the society to which they
live in
and to which they belong also volunteers
have the opportunity to offer their
assistance in various Fields such as
health education social services and so
on everyone needs a little bit everyone
needs a little bit of volunteering in
their life it may be a lot of work it
does not matter as long as it's
okay cut that one
it still may change someone else's love
in the better way
as a teacher
as a teacher and based on based on many
of my students responses
based
my personal opinion as a teacher and
based on uh a lot of a lot of students
responses I've come across a lot of
opportunities to help people and do
volunteering
whether it's in the school in the
community around the family chores and
there's a lot of ways that you can try
and make a difference when it comes to
volunteering at this point in time it is
very important for me and for other
students to develop into a better
version of ourselves
this can be achieved by doing voluntary
work and volunteering can be highly
productive and it is a great way for us
as part of the society and the part of a
larger Community to connect better with
a community around us
a few hours a day the park doing
voluntary work can bring a lifetime of
happiness into a child's life who goes
to the park every day as researchers
have shown that an average teenager
spends almost nine hours a day using
social media and scrolling down their
phones or their laptops faced with
Statistics like this one it is clearly
obvious that all of us not excluding
myself need to spend more time Outdoors
doing voluntary work rather than sitting
all day long doing nothing but scrolling
in our social media giving help to the
community is one of the most fulfilling
experiences one could get it is widely
known that having free time in our hands
is an issue as students and as teachers
as a teacher myself I think we have a
lot of things to deal with such as
school daily chores and we have a lot we
can do even though we do not have a lot
of free time it is important to make
time to do at least some volunteering
work volunteering is also beneficial if
you want to boost your educational
experience and also gain a lot of new
skills it keeps the mind and body
healthy and in motion all the time
volunteering helps us give up bad habits
and it is an enjoyable and easy way to
explore our true passions volunteering
empowers the individual to better their
life once you step out of your room and
start volunteering you will learn a lot
more about Humanity
volunteering shows you how giving humans
are even when they do not have what to
give the community we live in today is
diverse and a lot of people may feel
down or may feel like they do not
deserve a place in this community in
this large community which is called
planet Earth but by volunteering we have
the chance to give the powerless a voice
and gather together to help make the
world a better place for us and for the
future Generations when volunteering you
may see that everyone has a story
everyone has different perspective on
life and different perspective on on on
love and on Humanity you get to learn a
lot about people and the difficulties
they go through as as Gandhi once said
the best way to find yourself is to lose
yourself in the service of others
and it is a very beautiful statement in
my opinion it is a statement I
completely agree with no harm is going
to be caused if we dedicate a little of
our time doing things that may help
those in need
by giving as much as we can we can also
create Infinity cycles of Joy giving
makes the world different and the more
we give the more we will receive
it's how it works doing good for others
can also boost our our own happiness let
alone others happiness
uh there's so much work to be done and
we all together is the future of this
world can do a lot just by just just by
volunteering the benefits that people
especially students get from
volunteering are that they manage to
acquire some skills that they have not
learned before from school which helps
them to have a professional training
some Studies have shown that students
who apply to different jobs and present
the volunteer work they have the
volunteering work they have done have a
greater advantage to be accepted in in a
certain job so accept Schools students
should do other activities which may
also be volunteering
volunteering should be a necessary
phenomenon for the society we are
building today and the last thing we're
going to say about this matter is a
quote by Helen Dyer
who says that volunteering is the voice
of the people put into action these
actions shape and mold the present into
a future of which we can all be proud
and thank you for listening to our
podcast I hope you enjoyed our modest
elaboration if you like this episode and
you're Keen to listening to similar
stuff join us in our next session next
week when we'll be recording our next
episode tackling a different topic as
always you can head over to our YouTube
channel to subscribe or to sign up to
our email list as well as check out all
the links and resources in the show
notes that's all for now see you next
time